today's guest is one of America's most
loved crossover comedians he has a
podcast called get some you may know him
from think like a man he's a very funny
guy and I I've run into him a couple
times recently and happy to have him
here today mr. Gary Owen
[Music]
dude no but thanks for your patient man
I'm sorry I was late to chiropractor bro
you think you look like this just
automatically done I'm always I always
think I'm ready to scare me because I
think they'll fix the problem yeah but
then they'll also [ __ ] up a little Mel
see you come back you know like this all
right my sixth vertebrae is great but
now this third one and they don't think
they do it just a little bit so we're
gonna give him eight months yeah and
then you know what I mean then I'll come
up with something oh you were hiking
oh yeah does it yeah they counted yeah
they put something into your bones that
we cruising Nick yeah they put something
to your bones that like oh well this
will yeah they set you it like three
months they set that knee at three
months I'm telling you that layup
nobody's ever gonna chiropractor just
stop yeah come back you mean it's hard I
don't trust them like they're like
mechanics yeah they like my can I get my
oil change and they bring out some
filter like this I got a Camaro Toyota
filter yeah they bring back uh they they
bring back a sunroof you don't even have
one yeah I've never I never in my life
have I gone and got oil changed when I
when I had shitty cars and they just
went alright nineteen dollars like bike
the thing says on the marquee yeah it's
you walk out at $60 like they get you on
something you had to like it's 19 that
means like your car cannot go yeah we
found a used squirrel in your catalytic
converter that's what they used to get
my dad with all the time
I had a mouse and your catalytic
converter is like a burger the guy like
just give me $40 man we'll handle it I
mean your flux capacitor you're not
gonna be able travel back in time
oh you time-traveling man we got to shut
you down yeah yeah government says a
$200 it's just written on the wall two
or niles for time traveling right yeah
it's coming baby yeah yeah chiropractors
dangerous man I went in there and uh
this lady laid me down to do she was I
think Scottish or something man [ __ ] I
felt Scottish buzz
she was back in there dude she was deep
at some point just want to go watch
Braveheart bro I can feel my
grandparents is building up in my cheeks
brush she had me just reminisce see some
professions should be women I don't like
the whole we're all the same like if I
got the dentist yeah I don't want a
dental assistant to be a dude yeah I
want some man hands and my molars yeah
nice soft female type [ __ ] know what I
mean that's some jobs should not be when
I had my knee surgery I remember I
couldn't I couldn't piss or [ __ ] so cuz
you want pills
yeah just knee surgery and I couldn't
eat until I pissed I couldn't not I
wasn't allowed to eat so the nurse came
in and they go look we can hear wait
that is now you want a catheter you
couldn't eat until you pissed yeah I
wouldn't eat anything I could drink
water but I wouldn't had to eat they had
to make sure everything was moving
correctly I guess after the surgery oh I
see what you're saying I thought this
was like some kind of like weird like
you were in that movie saw some no no no
like you get out of surgery and then
they're like you know just guys the guys
with you now you got a piss yeah or you
can eat anything so it been a while so
the the lady nurse came in and she
literally goes look here we can do the
catheter and get the piss and they can
eat um you know are you we could wait a
couple more hours where we gonna do I'm
starving
just do it she's an hour you come
through with me doing her would you like
me get a guy to do it I literally went
why would I want a guy I remember
looking they're like so really people
say that I go and all that thing was I
was trying to tell her like look it's
not where it should be yeah right now at
surgery and you know it's very Ken Jong
hangover pop it off right now yeah yeah
that's true especially like a fireman or
something I don't want somebody be like
yeah we're sending barb up if you're in
a burning building right [ __ ] barb doll
I'm [ __ ] balls professions got to be men
and women yeah even when I was in the
Navy when I joined the Navy women
weren't allowed on combat ships right so
women had it made they were on shore
duty and we're on shore duty you get
extra money they give you extra money to
go get an apartment downtown
it's a nine-to-five job when you're sure
duty when you're on a ship it sucks
because you're in racks that are three
high
you know berthing area sucks there's no
privacy but women there's a few women
that were fighting for equal rights and
I was thinking why the [ __ ] would you
want to be on a ship yeah you got it
made right now it's always like a few
women we wanted the same I'm like this
stupid I mean it literally makes their
quality life worse right and better
they could've shut up and been fine but
do you think that some of them actually
want that or do you think it's some
people that just want to they just have
to argue for something sometimes and
they just want to win yeah that doesn't
benefit they want to win right they
don't even realize you're not really
winning yeah you lose enough of this and
if you asked a lot of a lot of men would
prefer to take a bullet for one or at
least when I was younger it seemed like
a lot of men would take a bullet for a
woman nowadays it'd be like you know
let's front some of these [ __ ] you
know put a back run well I will say when
you're when I was first in Navy and
women weren't allowed on combat ships I
the first ship I was on had women the
second one didn't anyway gotta be
banging them I just got to be around
some women man you go you go for a month
in the middle of the ocean with a
thousand dudes and you don't see one
female and I should have [ __ ] your
head a little does it man you come back
you raid a bank precious oh yeah dang
are you ready to bang semi-precious yeah
like wanna go steal some movie did your
mom hurt you it's like even when you're
out at sea when you're out at sea with
women on ships the first couple weeks
and you some of the women you're like ah
I'm good ya know and then muffin you're
like you've been working out you know
and then bye-bye two months it's it's
800 holly berries on that ship Wow
there's dang Stockholm Syndrome it is
I'm seeing the same women day-to-day you
start to just man gravitate oh yeah
remember I remember so you're so you're
saying though so then there is a it
sounds like there is a real advantage to
just having women around even on the
boat there is something nice about just
there being an opposite sex around oh
yeah like us
you ain't gotta be mess around and touch
them just a walk by have a descent right
of a woman did you know that a woman's
around yeah is something I mean
something ease the tension yeah I mean
even if you even if there's innocence I
was single so even if there's NSM
flirting like we had this one girl her
name was love I'll never forget it
best ass right and maybe had we had
young dungarees blackly and him love
oh yes black lady uh she was dating a
couple of the Chargers cuz we were
staged San Diego and to be a Navy girl
dating a couple NFL ballplayers like you
hadn't look I'm good could you're up
against the top of the top competition
yeah and I just remember her stencil was
sewn in but I'd still would be like you
know I was a cop and I was a Navy
I bet love them see your stencil she
turn around like are you good because
the stencil ain't right you gotta tell
him to go fix it and mark it in because
some people have markers some people
sewed it in her Sony and I said like
look that stencil I was good for me
dude I wonder if it's the same girl work
you know a love I know girl him love San
Diego a young black woman yeah but I
don't she wasn't from seen ago she was
Stacy to San Diego
yeah she had me from the South the way
her build was she had to be from the
south yeah all over some grits I want to
see really yeah yeah yeah I'm it I um
what someone's gonna ask you about just
a second ago were talking about the
military oh yeah they used to have a
thing so I went and did it all just some
just different military base tours and
stuff I'm sure you've done some of those
and they had one we went to Guantanamo
Bay and they had the term Gitmo pretty
and it was like after a couple days down
there you're like yeah that lady dude
keep me away from her and by five days
down there you're like hey where's that
like right fact yeah any ship man any
man at the any military base you're like
damn bird ed is looking hot as [ __ ] Lord
Pascale yeah they had a big girl named
galaxy was her name I remember galaxy
Wilson her last name is galaxy first
name galaxy Wilson brother like damn
galaxy moons over my hammy right that's
sold assist blast me into that ass and
the sphere bro
um dude thanks so much for coming in man
yeah no problem what's going on live in
Cincinnati huh
well look man I know you like to work in
a lot of the black circles someone was I
thought that's why I got here early I
gonna prove to him we're not all like
that I feel stuck in traffic
whoa he's in LA I guess I didn't see
that coming you know way to plan ahead
Theo do you um so you you've had a great
you've had probably the greatest career
for someone that doesn't live in Los
Angeles or New York mm-hmm maybe I don't
know yeah I never I lived here for a
little bit but my career took off really
when I left went back to Ohio cuz you
know that I mean that never happens but
that's not most people's story yeah why
would I would fly out whenever I was
needed in LA or New York yeah you know
you just kind of mm-hmm
yeah you love it I like I don't know
neither I hear I was talking to your
guys before I got here about you know
there's very much a click the comics or
comics mm-hmm you guys are like your own
little clique you know cuz you see each
other so much and I'm holy not in a loop
I'm almost like a Bigfoot right there's
sightings of me oh yeah in LA like you
leave when you saw me the airport oh
yeah oh well it's almost kind of nice
because it's almost like you're then
like a celebrity to LA oh yeah cuz I've
never seen cuz you're yeah you're like
so rare it's like yeah I wouldn't be
surprised if I saw Dwayne the rock
Johnson I've seen him twice in LA I've
only seen you once in LA and that was at
the airport yeah way out yeah we deliver
in Minnesota where were you going that
weekend uh I don't know yeah we're in
Minnesota remember that that was the
layover yeah beautiful Airport too big
though that's a big-ass Airport jeez
it's almost too big yeah I think the
vetro dome somewhere in there I remember
at one point I remember crossing a
40-yard line at somebody somebody
somebody fumbled around it boss needs
attached to the airport just watch the
game from the side when la la tout la
the airport's got the hotels right there
Detroit's got that Westin
right in it oh yeah five a three-hour
layover did on my sometimes I'll bust
the coin and get that get that lay down
for a little while well they get a rule
Atlanta's got the minute sweets you seen
that you can rent a room of like an hour
oh wow I don't know what is like $30 I
did it I got no I had like I don't like
I was I was coming back from Japan hmm I
landed at like 5:00 in the morning and
my next flight was like 11 so I bought
that thing for three hours and was he
good yeah it's like a Jerome room it's
got cable outlets a bed you know the
bathroom you have to leave not you not
to go in the hallway but there's a
bathroom for for the pods but it's like
a little pod it's cool though you know
what I was in Australia a couple weeks
ago and they had at the airport in this
one area that it's had like these kind
of like look like a big molar actually
with them with a roll top like those
roll-top desk
and you could get in there like an egg
yeah like an egg okay mark mark Mork and
Mindy
yep you pay like three or four dollars
and getting that egg and that's that and
yet it's right in the airport I mean
just literally you could walk I mean you
broke there were kids running around
through them playing games and [ __ ] and
they're in the egg locked in you're in
there sleeping yeah I mean I think you
lock yourself in from the area lady in
there I don't know make a little bit of
[ __ ] what you doing Australia perfect
salad bruh
yeah Joe's over there I never I'm never
outside of military bases I've never
only place I've been outside the country
is Squam and London mmm that's been it
well Canada but that's it's kind of
America too
yeah Austria is kind of Canada but way
like it's Canada with more of a criminal
element you know cuz a lot of criminals
they that whole country based on
criminal yeah or you know people that
dig from crime where did you get that
statistic from crime uh just from being
like guys buying it like really I go
never heard that he is just breaking off
[ __ ] yeah like Ohio Ohio I was founded
by a Capone you know he was running
drugs through there and he just named it
Ohio do you ever feel left out because
you don't live in LA or New York no no
never do I'm so busy as it is yeah you
know even if I
when I get off the road the last thing I
wanna do is go to a comedy club cuz I do
it so much well I know a lot of the guys
in LA they're you know they're there at
the comedy clubs every night and I did
that when I was out here so I feel like
I got it out of my system but it hurts a
different vibe at the Comedy Store now
heard there's different management and
ownership and everything else cuz I ate
when I first started I did the whole
waited in line for three hours to open
mic oh yeah and and this is not an
indictment I'm Mitzi shore I'm sure
she's a nice lady but what she did to me
I was like I will never perform here
that's why I'm never there see I see huh
oh I wait in line I did the I did what
you're supposed to do for like two three
weeks right and I got I got picked a
showcase mm-hmm
so five five a showcase that night and
it was your other ones it was for women
I was only dude
mmm I don't know who the other women
were but there was four women and me and
I was the fifth so to forward me the
only black guy to performative or pretty
much it's I do you remember the other
people were Chris Tucker Chappelle so I
don't know why dang a pic nah it was
full but when when I went up and you
know I get five minutes yeah I looked in
the back of the original room and she
was like holding court with the four
girls and wasn't watching me and then I
got a call the next day and there yeah
you get picked to be a regular I said
what and not to sound conceited but I
clearly had the best set yeah like it
was even close look we know we have a
good set and we don't and I was like I
didn't get picked and then when I found
out the girls did I was like I'm out and
I'll never perform here so you had a
real rig that you had a real resentment
then towards her a little bit yes
because I felt like I did what you were
supposed to do now if none of us would
have got picked I'd have been like all
right but in honestly I knew my stuff
wasn't hacky you know what I mean I knew
it was some original stuff yeah so I was
just like I think it picked it's just
amazing even watch me so for whatever
reason it is what it is but I've never
performed never been back who didn't
make you feel like it wasn't fair like
I'm just curious
I mean yeah you hear all kinds of stuff
about Mitzi - I mean obviously you know
she's run like one of the best clubs you
know like I think
like I don't know all of it but like her
you know she got the club finally from
her husband or something I think like
there was some other ownership you know
you hear that she never paid people
people went on strike you know you hear
all kinds of stuff I mean you know
there's tons of history out of that
building I mean she was also a woman
that started a business you know so like
I think that was a you know the one a
lot of women doing that in the comedy
space at the time but yeah I mean you
hear all kinds of stuff that she was
dating half the comedian's I mean
there's tons of things you hear yeah
I'm saying it's probably nice lady I'm
not saying she's a bad person but that I
burned that night I was like man [ __ ]
did that make you feel like you weren't
gonna have any opportunities in LA
overall oh no I it got me all fired up
and a lot of people know this Iran Iran
the the main room for two years on guide
Tori's Fat Tuesday mm-hmm cuz I'm in st.
Louis and guys some I got let it go I'm
too busy I so you can't let it go dude
that's like that's like the black spot
on Tuesday at The Comedy Store yeah I
wouldn't take it over I said I won't she
[ __ ]
I was running me and my wife was running
it and nobody knew I was behind it
because I just wouldn't show up I was
just but it was funny because my wife
would like we were booking it right and
then people would be like talking [ __ ]
about other comics and stuff like comics
do sometimes and she come back and give
me feedback and sometimes if you help me
I was like really but I never held
against them I wouldn't like not book
somebody think of all but was just like
I just thought comics do that I can cuz
there's a there's a little bit of [ __ ]
in all of us oh yeah you know what I
mean so you're gonna have days and
nights where you're you're just you want
to blame somebody when you don't realize
it's just a business it is what it is
yeah that's another thing yeah it's just
a business it's like yeah I mean even
going back to the Mitzi short thing it
psychic you know people could say that
you know you'll hear that she didn't pay
comics but you also don't know if she
was getting a shitty ordeal because she
was a woman in certain circles you know
you just don't know it's like you don't
know how like what the business is
always you don't know everybody's
hanging everybody's you know everybody's
dealing with it mhm yeah you know you
know with her see and open-mike errs all
day every day
she might been having like I'm [ __ ]
done today oh yeah time to see this guy
or maybe some man in the business have
been a dick to her that day and she's
like you know what I just saw you eat
right we don't know you just don't know
back then I was like [ __ ] his [ __ ] now
it's more just the story it's my story
right you know it's not I'm not mad
I've never said a bad word about her in
public or anything it's just it is what
it happened yeah it's like but that
night
[ __ ] I was pissed I could imagine [ __ ]
the Commodore [ __ ] sheet oh man Jersey
Shore shorted I was done
want to go surf it [ __ ] you man go to a
pool [ __ ] Gulf Shores Alabama yeah [ __ ]
floor Bama the bar the shitty bar that's
now if you always get a date rate but to
do music I'm sorry but look if you're
gonna need a day rate goodnight rape to
some you know some easy listening you
know what I'm saying spanner bro I don't
want to get day road test and AM Trick
Daddy
you know what I'm saying I want to get
neighbors Kennard yes okay this yeah I'm
not British Rob I'm not agreeing with
you did him venomous animal go in us he
had definitely agreement mode
I get that in podcast I'm talking to
somebody I just have no idea so that's
what's going on to disagree I can agree
with them yeah okay everything about
killing your whole family like that's a
great idea
yeah but yeah it's like sometimes you
just don't know it's like you know yeah
it's like we just don't know sometimes
though what everybody else is dealing
with you know that's right yeah looking
back on it's just like I just I'll never
forget as long as I live the four women
standing around her and she's just
holding court like yeah I'm about okay
I'm reading what they're saying like you
got to work on this you do this isn't
this but it looked like they was all
hell every time oh right now I'm are
here going yeah no to me I want to stop
it like hey Mitch I'm up
it's my third Sunday wait in line for
three [ __ ] hours gonna get five
minutes that's going through my brain
it's such a helpless feeling to when you
you can't do that and you put the mic
back in the stand and you walk off going
this is pointless this was [ __ ]
pointless
and then when I would drive by and see
the guys in line I don't it was like a
Tuesday at a wait in line that was like
the long liner from the combi yeah for
open Mikan and I Drive by it and see
just for the next couple years but I
want to be like where's your time Wow
say you better yeah man I never looked I
can totally go through that moment
you're on stage and you see the person
who's supposed to be paying attention to
you and you're already nervous there's
already a lot going on I mean this is
like a moment in the Sun even get that
opportunity to showcase at the Comedy
Store and then the other people that
have already gone on they had their time
to be in front of her now they're all
talking to her and you have to still be
doing your jokes your mind is locked in
and even it could be complete darkness
in the room I remember when I was doing
it in New York for us stst right who
passes at the Comedy Cellar
and she's over in the dark and I don't
know where she is but then at a certain
point I knew exactly where she was in
the dark paying attention to me you know
it's like you can just feel like the
spot in the dorm where somebody in the
room is that supposed to be judging you
yeah and to think that they're not even
paying attention and you still have to
do these jokes and you don't even care
for other people in the room even see
yeah it's a helpless feeling so helpless
to [ __ ] so help us bro I kind of
breastfeed and be a man you know it's
like Jerry's deli afterwards oh yeah
it's meat only broth your breasts be
what you want and you're a man yeah
Jenner milk just today The Hollywood
Reporter named Adam egit the new manager
at The Comedy Store and SD two of the 40
most powerful people in comedy Wow and
there you go it's like and then it's
like you look years later I mean it's
like you know Pauly's like you know
paulie's always you know he's always
trying to be supportive he's always
trying to stay creative you got the the
file that has passed away the law of
just the store even staying like all the
times it was supposed to be sold I heard
it's a different vibe I didn't spend lot
of time there but I heard it's
completely different now it's different
now man it's very supportive but I you
know what a lot of that is is I think
more than any other time in the history
of stand-up like commerce can control
their own narrative now right through
through
podcasting you know what I mean just
your social media YouTube I mean you can
build your audience you don't need
somebody to say give you like the yes
yeah you can do it on your own you know
even with you know I've gotten to know
you through through the podcast networks
yeah much I mean outside of road rules
you were amazing on that yeah well I
mean I was a kid you know I know that's
the thing man I I've always I follow you
from afar because I saw you on Last
Comic Standing you were like the
internet guy yeah I me and Josh wolf cuz
when I saw you I go that's the [ __ ]
from Road rules right you know what I
mean
yeah and when you did Road what year was
that you did roses 9999 and you you were
like a midseason replacement or
something right then you call me you
were there from the record yeah
did someone get kicked off that year or
something and some I knew came in no
[ __ ] it I'm thinking a lot of seasons
there's a million seasons something like
this [ __ ] I'm taking a Cyrus from Boston
yeah but the reason I always fall like
that just the 90s I'll say is I was in
the Navy and I tried to get on the real
world uh-huh I could see all there
easily the Boston cast and I remember my
buddy this is before the internet you
had to write a letter I wrote a letter
to be in a Murray and they need to tell
you we're gay that we're getting have a
letter even though no no I told him I
like black women oh yeah perfect house
would be me with seven black girls oh
you know what I mean and then here's
what's funny
who you Scott Storch be simply girls you
know and then they said they sent me a
letter back like I got a letter back and
they said put yourself on tape so my
buddy worked at good guys
so we said like literally a hundred TVs
up so everything I did was magnified by
a hundred Wow and then I had like a
black girl walk in and I and then uh and
then they asked me to come up and get
interviewed and I got interviewed and
then I I didn't get it obviously but it
was the Boston like 96 season oh yeah
and what was crazy is I'm active duty so
how would I have done it anyways right I
studied your left you'd had asked I
leave they might not giving it to you so
when I see that season there was the the
black girl I went to Stanford that
didn't like interracial dating but then
they went on vacation she bang the white
dude on vacation I went I was supposed
to bang her Oh like literally I was like
I was I was supposed to bang her that
was supposed to be I was watching it
like then I see what you did there I was
supposed to be the Heather at Martha's
Vineyard like this and then it was funny
because when I sit in all the tape like
I like black girls do me with seven
black girls a big arch of that season
was Cyrus dated a lot of white women and
the black girl didn't approve of it so
in a way it was like they addressed what
I had talked about video you know what I
mean I was like that out as far as like
I would have been a great asset yeah and
that season was kind of boring yeah
Boston yeah I don't even remember it I
remember the first season of the real
world I remember was when real world
Hawaii when I mean I remember some of
the other ones but the first one I
watched I just remember tech jumping
into that swimming pool naked I don't
know
yeah was he and he got [ __ ] and I
didn't notice that why did they blurt
him out like 18 inch sensor bar yeah but
I thought he out of the TV yeah he was
only the first like start getting like
the well no they were the guy from the
first season was the the ripped guy from
New York Oh Eric nice arrogant he was
the first one he got like spin-off and
[ __ ] like yeah he was a real G but uh
but yeah man I'm trying to think of um
I'm trying to think of uh I don't know
where a train of thought went here
reality TV in the Comedy Store yeah yeah
I mean yeah I think oh you mentioned
that SD and Adams got this that got
those things yeah oh and then you said
yeah it's like people can make their own
destinies now it's like yeah you don't
have to have like I mean one of the
reasons why some people got into
podcasting was like I couldn't find a TV
show or anything I could even be
represented out here
you know like they were not they're not
putting anybody from like I don't
consider I mean I'm from the south on a
consider myself like a redneck though
you know like but they're not putting
any they weren't putting anybody that
even represented me I felt like so it
was like I had to start a podcast even
this you know have anything to be able
to say anything I felt like yeah I think
people gravitate to podcasts because you
you are unfiltered ya know like I did on
mine last well you got talked about an
argument I had backstage with my opener
really and it was a legit I was throwing
food at him I'm so pissed because he
yelled at me wasn't about the food it
was like would you throw in him I got
him fried rice and egg rolls oh man he
was Asian
Oh Cambodian wait let me see what
happened and Cambodian let's be honest
dude it's Asian bro but it's also a
little something else okay there be a
while even Asian people are like like
going out there it is ways and roads a
past Asian bro you're out there dude
well here's what happen because I want
to hear about this man because people
often say that you're hard to deal with
so I want to hear without bryan callen
we talked about that I'm talking I was
talking your guys before I got on here I
go I got dude I go you know the
Internet's notorious for anybody saying
good at best you get on your [ __ ]
they see something bad I get DMS and
Twitter tags and everything and the the
Bryan Callen Brendan Schaub when they
when I all my wife got profile on Delta
and they brought it up and they go and
Bryan goes yeah I heard that guys hard
to deal with so I watched it it really
was Bryan even said he goes I don't know
why I said that I should but they didn't
they call you the dude they call you the
pink Chris Tucker that's what I hear oh
think I'm like the only one like he was
the only black guy with a John Deere
deal I mean I'm the only black guy at
the barbers I don't know I got a barber
shop where my pictures on the haircut
yeah you're white guy you want that Gary
old right there on the poster
don't let guys of me know uh let me see
what happened in Dallas
oh not hard to deal with but it's not
about the food that I threw it was that
yelled at me as a
me through the food because I before I
went onstage you know comical food isn't
the best right I'm over 40 and trying to
be good so I literally just told him I
said go anywhere just get some brown
rice and teriyaki chicken that's
anywhere right so they they they
couldn't find the place that they said
they're gonna order from they couldn't
get it so I get off stage so you know
you're hot
you got three shows that night you just
want to eat you're like okay get your
palates ready for some and they ordered
Thai food and I was like I don't you
guys know me I don't like Thai food so
automatic I'm like why would you order
Thai food ya have anything you could got
me a salad right so then I open it the
vegetables looked older I just look bad
oh look like now I was like so now I'm
not not happy the only look good and you
know Asian food comes in two big
containers was this big container
noodles and veggies and chicken I go
that looks good so I take the fork and
and out the County Club brought us
plates I take the fork and I'm taking
some noodles and put on a plate and I
was gonna take some other stuff too and
just make a plate of little samples
everything so of a container my opener
comes in say goes Eidos are mine those
are mine those are my I said okay I was
like I'm just gonna take a little bit is
that okay
he was I oh yeah it's fine okay I take
noodles and then he takes it and it's a
big container and he puts his fork in
and immediately starts eating it so we
still got two other people in the green
room that's got to eat and I looked at
my said say you know you've been selfish
right like you should I'm thinking in my
brain you should have offered something
to the other people in the room right
and he goes huh
I got you know you've been selfish right
and he just went from zero to ten
because I'm not bad shellfish and there
was when he yelled at me I went what it
was I had a movie and I just grabbed the
nearest this container of fried rice I
go get off and as he's leaving the room
I'm throwing one egg rolled a time ago
get the [ __ ] yeah he gets out it's like
the Laotian Olympics he comes back in
and he yells again he said I was just
trying to I and I did there's one more
egg run I said get the [ __ ] out he gets
out right so then I calm down I go okay
I probably overreacted right right my
Romans are Brad he explains that he just
broke it down because
he's got a real live voice man I just
think uh I think it was hot he was
hungry and the food wasn't there that
you wanted and in says-- mine those were
his noodles yeah so you was eating his
noodles I go I go yeah you probably
right
pro-reactive somebody just yelled at me
man actually I could have a discussion
about it it was him yelling that set me
off and then we're laughing about an
hour later but I talked about it on my
podcast right last week I'm telling
people start at no point I say I was
right or wrong but just telling a story
but some people were like uh you know he
was wrong Gary or some people was like
I'm looking at you did for you like a
diva oh those were his noodles the funny
part is that's the part is the word
noodles makes it fun yeah we got a
argument over some noodles Brian and
Brendan Schaub so that's why he was
upset no but here's a funny [ __ ] about
the whole thing I didn't throw my plate
of food I had already made my say had
his noodles in his hand one person he
indeed was Brad yeah Roman who had
nothing to do with the Arts you met he
goes he just broke it down here's my
thing happy you that is the word it is a
word throw because sometimes you'll have
a long day of traveling you don't have a
chance to eat anything you'll get up
early then layover is really fascinated
be thirty minutes you have to get to
your gate and so then next thing you
know you've had a coffee and a muffin or
something or and a banana you finally
get to the place you you know you maybe
have a snack or something where you go
on stage and then you have to do the
first show you get off you want to eat
that's your time to finally get
something to eat right and your palates
ready for something yeah and that's not
like an extravagant dish like no brown
rice interrogate chickens you should be
able to get that yeah you should be able
to get it man innate in the and
especially if he's Cambodian do you
can't come up with a little teriyaki
chicken pop-up [ __ ]
Yuda Cambodian host somebody if I asked
you for [ __ ] doughnuts or something
you know you don't know how to come up
with a coupler I asked you for you know
a couple of Cornish game hens or
something it's like asking me you know
where can I get some quiche yeah
you know tuna casserole I can make you
that I'm gonna interrupt this
conversation just to say today's episode
is brought to you by Ridge wallet
sometimes you you find yourself in a
pasture sometimes you find yourself on a
plane or on a Ledge and sometimes you
find yourself on a ridge and that's what
you need now maybe a Ridge for yourself
or a ridge for a loved one Ridge is that
front pocket carry it's a wallet but
it's for the front it's a perfect
rectangular piece that really you know
you put your credit cards in there put
your ID in there and your money in
earrings get specific
quick carrying around your Ronia stuff
in an old-fashioned rear pocket carry
some people in their wallet you're
looking at again again I got they got a
little stick of gum and maybe a hotel
key from from a from a budget in
somewhere off the off the interstate off
i-75 don't be like that anymore
get that front pocket carry from Ridge
they also have phone cases they also
have knives visit Ridge wallet comm
slash tpw and used code tpw at checkout
for 10% off that's code tpw for 10% off
at Ridge wallet comm 20 diamond we
worked together at tone remember the
charity basketball the basketball thing
the basketball referee Who am I thinking
of brother Oh Tony some of that and uh
was that a few bad his name is Jimmy he
beat you with my brothers
Tony brothers yeah I forgot about that
nobody is a sweet man and he was not
happy that night he was not happy that
night because they booked they they
overbooked the theater and the weekend
he said you guys knew I was bringing the
show here I'm doing this for the
community and you booked like two other
urban comedy shows around it oh really
there was like one the week before and
like one two weeks after and he was like
you killed my show I didn't know that
yeah that's why he went on stage and
told him because I'm not happy about
this I was like Dan I never seen
somebody go up and thank the people for
being there but then go off on the venue
and Unthank the venue right
beautiful venue yeah there's a beautiful
venue man yeah you crushed him and I'd
never seen you
I mean I'd seen you on film and I'd seen
you on um on the internet and stuff but
I've never seen you onstage with yeah
it's a different beast and you yeah you
really really I get that a lot
anybody knows like that really well I it
sounds conceited but there's a different
energy with a black audience yeah and be
awakened by a stick bro it was black
tastic dude it was Howard homecoming
yeah it was I mean there was people
doing that but we're excited though what
yeah I'm the I'm the white guy yeah for
black people so you're the extremely
strong fit you're the very physical and
talented Michael Rapaport people call
you hmm I can see that yeah and uh yes
if it's it's a different energy and I
you know like I said my my latest
special um last week in San Antonio and
even my agent at UTA hadn't seen me live
in years and he goes I I forgot it was
like that and I know that sounds
conceited right no it does a different
energy that's your drive yeah just not
only that it's just a reaction when I
come onstage like right I am V I'm like
I said I am black famous yes many black
people walk by if they don't know my
name they don't my face oh you're
Frederick Douglass almost I mean it's
like you
Freddie day who else a couple of us I'm
trying to think of famous yeah white
people that are um Larry Bird
yeah Larry Bird ain't going too far yeah
it's very yeah I'm trying to think of
famous white guys that are real famous
in the black community but it's crazy
like it is a different black Hollywood
and Hollywood is different because I
heard stories about Philip Seymour
Hoffman and I don't know if it's true
but I got it from reliable source he
used to go to like the Starbucks in the
urban neighborhoods because he could sit
down and read and be left alone oh wow
and I nobody knew who he was
I like this he ger like the Magic
Johnson Starbucks that's great and just
like read and this might be like to that
and somebody told me they go yo that
dude from that movie at do you know I'm
free I'm free
idiot that dude from Boogie Nights and
you do the opposite you've got a like
nice wait I gotta I gotta Salt Lake to
get away
I got a Park City oh I was in DC and it
was fun I was i I was telling about
stage I go dude I'm in DC I did not get
stopped one time by white person Wow in
five days but I couldn't go a block doc
doc the got me was the homeless
[ __ ] stop me oh you couldn't go
a black homeless stop that again yeah
yeah that's when you know this is
homeless a new exhibit but if they don't
know me I'm that so boy
oh yeah that's so boy right here that's
so boy what's funny is though they'll
have a whole conversation but won't know
my name yeah oh yeah and then it's fun
to argue at the cells yeah that's you
yeah you know that's you you not you are
you you right yeah as you yeah you know
as you they walk away and it's on their
friend that's him on it is him their
corner for it yeah saw that dude yeah
yeah you know you you know it's like a
who's on first that never you know you
you know you you know you you
dude it was fire man but um yeah do you
feel like though that
do you ever was that your plan for the
beginning kind of have a black audience
or did that just kind of come up like
well you don't you don't choose your
audience they choose you right I just
got on BT early right I thought you got
your really your break yeah like I
would've didn't Telemundo if I could've
spoke Spanish huh
you know you break in this useful you
just wanna be funny and get onstage
yeah and I just my my every TV
appearance was was be et in the
beginning and for some reason the movies
I got in were black lead actors yeah the
own movie I've done that was a all-white
cast was a movie called college and it
probably did the worst of the box off
how do you think there's something about
you that black people that really
attracts black culture that like is it
like a like some a way that you look or
a way that you well I uh deal Hughley he
explode my myself down to my myself yeah
he just said you know you
you're authentic and he said and your
stories are your real life it's not like
you're up there just doing a joke to get
a laugh like you're really telling like
you really went to a black church right
like your joke was that experience from
your perspective right you know and I
think I think a lot of times too I'm not
putting down people I'm just saying it's
different right you know there's no
put-down because I don't I T what what
what gets on my nerves when I see white
stand-ups going from a black audience
and just completely put down white
people right you know I think it on bike
and I haven't seen some like you in the
audience but I do we don't think like
that right we don't hate white people
what are you talking about you know what
I mean right
that [ __ ] I'll be like this dude yes oh
yeah it sounds soaked it just it makes
my skin crawl
well thanks half of LA these days man I
feel like I get out like if I get on
stage there's a lot of so many comedians
who are like you know like apologizing
for their white privilege and [ __ ] like
that and that's fine if someone feel
like that it was that big of a thing in
their life you know where somebody came
in their room and they were young or
like hey you're white you know we're
gonna be voices of white males in my
life than black dude all the bugs have
been cool yeah the white dudes in my
life I'm like what the [ __ ]
get away from my stepdad I can't stand
out [ __ ] man
good lord but yeah my step there was
every bad black stereotype really ever
you know people you know black guys or
ladies I'm like nah Rod's lazy they
don't look at no job now Ron get a job
who the [ __ ] you talking about must've
did every time I heard of a bad stares
about black males everyone stood there
that's hilarious I was like he's worse
than all this [ __ ] that's you describe
him right now early on did you have a
lot of stories like in your standup that
with black culture is that why you think
they like well when I started in San
Diego uh I was trying to get on the
Comedy Store in the Jolla and everything
but you know with open mic you're lucky
to get up you know the open mic night
was Sunday nights and then that was it
and then I was like couple black guys in
a navy with talking about all these
other spots I could get on stage but you
had to go where the by people were you
know a lot of mainstream commerce they
don't want to do that
as I wear okay I'll go there I'm just
naive everything right and then and then
I would start doing like karaoke bars
like I would if I couldn't get onstage I
would go like at karaoke and it was a
mic and it was speakers right I was like
instead of singing I would tell jokes
and make like people got to know me like
oh that's the funny dude he's not gonna
sing he's gonna tell some jokes that's
pretty cool you know what I mean it said
I would do like musical bits not singing
right my jokes was about music I
remember it's not a very good joke so
you might lose some listeners Oh enough
shitty jokes there in the pocket yeah
it's my my I remember my my first joke I
to always tell the Cokie bars it's about
Janet Jackson I'd be like I go have you
guys noticed like Janet Jackson like her
first song was uh let's wait a while I
go then her second album the song was
come back to me I said well [ __ ] you
told him to wait and now you're telling
to come back I go now this latest album
was any time any place
I know somebody turned out muhfucka I
mean and then that like open up like
okay just talking [ __ ] about musicians
so a lot of it was just like whatever
songs was hot yeah I'll just make fun of
them at the karaoke spot do you think
that you um are actually white and you
have to like be black in the morning
when you get up what do you mean like if
we move the switch on the back of you to
be like well guys I hope everything is
going well what am I like Caitlyn Jenner
down I know I'm black but there's no
surgery to fix it like god I wish I
could just switch this a little bit no
it works for me being the being like the
I don't see fish out of water because I
am kind of a fish out of water but I'm
very comfortable in the water right I'll
say like that yeah I've never liked a
lot of times I think we feed into what
the media tells us yeah when and that's
not been in my experience like oh yeah
dude I don't let yeah I mean there's
dated a dear dealings with people uh I
don't I don't see too many people just
out-and-out hating somebody else cuz uh
skin color alone yeah totally now I mean
I'm more scared of white guys with
tattoos on their face and brand sagging
yeah these days it's starting to change
well they don't scare anymore I'm scared
what I'm scared of is some of you know
with a lot of you know people of
different cultures especially when you
have black and white people having
children you're gonna start you start to
get a lot of soft black dudes man
I'm serious bruh these Gray's bro I seen
a man do you can be telling my kids I
saw so uh these some of these mixed kids
they're [ __ ] slow it's like Oh
welcome you wanted white [ __ ] you got it
man welcome to these [ __ ] layups
enjoy these layup well that's the
problem when you are mixed because the
the black and you says dunk it and then
why Hughes has passed it out and you're
just [ __ ] confused then you become
Steph Curry to shoot threes yeah take it
to the hole no you got a share but the
black [ __ ] dude it we had who we had a
we had a black guest and you know we
were talking about getting scared I know
is it Donnell Rawlings and I've always
felt like that black people don't get
nervous I always felt like Dean you're
on stage no period like do you ever like
white people always felt like we have
like a thing where we get nervous and
like black people don't have that like I
like I remember asking him all like dude
do you guys get nervous like it just
doesn't we well the thing about is white
people have way more skeletons rad
closet than black people right you know
black people like historically
especially in this country their
histories laid out there yeah
white people we did a lot of dirty [ __ ]
but we don't want to talk about it yeah
we did some dirty like I was just in
Tulsa a couple weeks ago and I I found
out about black Wall Street you heard
about that
uh-uh in 2020 one will be the honey
anniversary and it was like this 36
block area of Tulsa that black you were
flourishing like they had though they
had supermarkets and doctors office in
clubs and restaurants and big homes they
they were like they were like living in
a bubble mm-hmm and all the side
this this black teenager got caught with
this white girl and didn't even caught
do anything they just got got caught
together alone in a building now and all
the white people came after this black
teenager and the sheriff was like no the
white girl's not pressing charges he and
do anything wrong and this mob mentality
happened and they just started like
literally murder and black people like
on the front porches and and they looted
the businesses and then the like
National Guard came in and bombed black
Wall Street like completely bombed it
and it was like for what yeah and then
they're like I'm sitting I'm like I
never even heard of this and then this
girl like gave me an entire breakdown of
what happened and then she said what's
crazy about the aftermath is like there
be like black women walking down the
street years later and they see a white
lady with like the her watch on or her
necklace and you just what you gonna do
you can't do anything oh that was from
one of their from their their store or
their house oh wow
you know what I mean it was like it's a
it's a dirty part American history and
I'm sure I would put money because it's
coming up in honey anniversary there'll
be a movie or a TV show about it oh yeah
soon yeah cuz I just heard I was like
what how did I hear about I've heard the
term black Wall Street I just didn't
know what it meant do you think
sometimes it too many movies and media
one alike or just making money even more
off of just rehashing a bad past instead
of like finding solution and stuff and
moving forward yeah I mean is is it's
it's part of our history though so right
happened do you feel like sometimes
though it's like they don't always give
like every side of the story feels like
sometimes there's only just just one
side of a story you know sometimes it's
like at a certain point aren't they just
using black people again like by by
using these stories just to make money
when a lot of people are it feels to me
like a lot of people are moving forward
and a lot and sometimes it's just like a
regurgitation of you know like how many
times can you make people that currently
like a slave movie you're making another
slave sometimes yeah it's like at what
point do you say look let's just make a
movie just you know how many times we
have to do we have to do this same exact
movie you know yeah you
I mean it's like because then they're
just using black people again because
I'm sure it's a lot of white ownership
that owns these studios to then once
again
well then I'm an attorney but this time
they're doing it under the guise of that
we're helping black America I mean
there's definitely a disconnect between
the the powers that be there that are
the head of these studios you know cuz
they don't they just don't know they you
know they do that's like we're stand-ups
I don't it's not get about stand-ups and
we talk about sitcoms and everything
else is is you know the state of sitcoms
are so bad right now because I'm the
head of a network I want to take a stand
as it's on the road grind in cuz I feel
like they have the pulse of what the
country is going through the flyover
States and you got guys in New York and
LA they don't they're not in Nebraska
right and Iowa they don't know what's
making those people tick oh and not only
that but then these same networks go and
make fun of those people and they like
didn't that like you know it just seems
like a lot of times that good people who
haven't done a lot of stuff wrong have
really been through enough but these but
it's just like how many times are we
gonna bring stuff up that something I
didn't do something I didn't have a part
of and I would never be a part of you
know but it's like I mean I don't do
what Central Park did you watch I
haven't seen yet and they see it I'm
never there was there's Avett is
something cool with that is you know it
definitely was those four boys got
railroaded yeah tada but you also see
when when one of them goes to pretty one
of them really had about Corey wise as
one of them like he he got it the worst
and he didn't do anything he just went
to go support his friend at the police
station basically Wow and they brought
him in and he's the one that caught the
worst did the most time had the roughest
time but they showed how one guard and
at Rikers was kind of a dick to him and
and was using them and he had to give
him like all this extra [ __ ] to protect
them basically and I don't know what
that girl was if you mixed they're black
I don't know
but then when I got transferred there
was a white guard that really looked out
for him
mmm you know was fair gave them books 3d
was in solitary you know what I mean and
it was just a and it was never brought
up it's not like the white cop helped me
it was just there and like I thought
there
cool house she made that apparent hmm
you know to me I noticed it Ryland
everybody else did but I noticed it
right he got a kid that don't trust
anybody if you're a railroad of all the
white people but it was the white guard
that would kind of went like it was
someone I can hurricane with Denzel
mm-hmm
remember the white guard was the one
that was like happy for him when he got
exonerated the and he was like looking
out for him a little bit in the prison I
remember that part
let me not believe it out it was the guy
I was the guy from cotton what is his
name he's in a lot of freakin movies man
my favorite movies name was bad boys not
with Will Smith the one with Sean Penn
when he was a teenager in prison you see
that one came out like 81 uh-huh that's
a great one years old yeah but it comes
out I saw the Wizard of Oz I came out in
46 you can't see him feel just cuz you
do dose one what I don't see movies
before tonight I didn't I don't think
walking in like a theater then that was
your bad boys look up bad boys with Sean
Penn that's a great [ __ ] movie man
really I love Sean Penn man 83 83 I'm
checking a great flick dude a brutal
though [ __ ] it that guy with the blond
hair curly hair dude yeah what's his
name
rainy Santorini
that's not a Santoni no he's got a
normal name Sam or Alice well fancy
Brown know is they plant that [ __ ]
guy's name is Clancy Brown what's his
name in the movie do you know I don't
know he was the blond hair guy there was
a picture of him you guys went away from
it
yeah the blond hair curly got that guy
who thinks Clancy Brown it's classy
Brian yeah you know that is he was in
yes Shawshank he was the garden Shaw say
it was bad he was in hurricane Wow
he looked out for uh Denzel and
hurricane hmm a guy's a great actor he
plays a lot of prison guards evidently
clearly chalti was a bad one
bad boys he was one of the gangsters he
was one of the kids in there because
it's shot it's about it's about guys
gonna this terrible juvie home hmm
okay watch it man good man chuckle watch
bad boys I would watch that do you feel
like when something's released in like
black culture you're like [ __ ] I gotta
watch this no I bet why am I not in it
yeah
when I see a white guy no black and I'm
like really yeah he can't promote like
that yeah can't promote like I could
promote you know I mean it's funny cuz
you know what do people think you were
movies that you were not in like at all
it's mouse bozos want it yeah the thing
I was in mouth was most wanna like we
started something here but as like some
people think I'm in power right now mice
and men of Myesha and man I could see
you in that no as a movies I all there
was we called the breaks with Mitch
Mulaney people think I was the leading
that really yeah he passed away like 10
years ago
I could see that man I'm trying to think
of some other people I get people think
you're Darren Carter if he got on HGH I
know that sometimes nah I don't like
nothing like they're they're starting to
San Diego hey there it's funny man you
put your in front of a big crowd brah I
don't know anybody that could kill us
harm any III killed like this he
murdered a man that's fine uh no when I
started staying up in San Diego
I was funny the first couple times I
would go to the comic store and sit in
the back and just watch em hmm
I remember it was like Bobby Lee Darin
Carter was that crew it I remember Darin
one time went up and uh got a heckler
and destroyed them and I went oh my god
this is the one yeah first time you see
a comic live deal with the heckler
you're like I gotta work on some [ __ ] I
gotta go I would have left yeah I gotta
find out who my real dad is yeah yeah
first time you see a comedy like an hour
strong you're like holy [ __ ] like five
minutes yeah when you first start that
five minutes seems like three hours oh
dude it's so and you're like oh that
third joke is gonna kill it you're only
only f3 you're like once you get to that
third when you guys know rider left
either you can take a right turn like
this is it I'm working this in the
mirror you know one guy drops a glass
during your first joke and it ruins over
your whole night yeah ruins your whole
drive home you living in knowledge the
crowd yeah like you on autopilot
I literally 9/11 could happen you're
just going to the building if there was
a there was like an open mic ER at like
a corporate event during 9/11 he would
not have acknowledged the buildings
fault he was still be like so then my
daughter
shake right there yeah you know buddy we
wouldn't even acknowledge it open mic
two more minutes yeah they light me oh
this is the fire department coming up we
got some news topics let's get into a
few Nick Scherr first up it's been kind
of a recurring story on this podcast but
the leader of the nexium quote/unquote
sex cult was convicted on all charges
this morning they got him
where's that at it was in LA
the Allison man that guy was the lead
yeah is that Elizabeth Warren's daughter
first of all that guy was lead of a sex
cult yeah yeah we had someone on from
the sex cult on the podcast that I
booked and the sex cult cured his
Tourette's Tourette's
but the reason what we didn't know we
yeah we only booked him because he had
Tourette's and we brought him in here
and the whole time he thought it was a
setup and we're gonna ask him about the
sex cult but then it came out throughout
the interview and yeah so we we've just
learned more about it and we have
Michael Rosenbaum in who was cast
members with aliceandmac who was also
she caught charges in this now what
about random huh
well look do you can't have people look
you can't have your sex cult 'is getting
into the neighbors sex cult your lord
you know I'm just saying man you can't
have you know I'm just amazed this guy
was the leader bro if Brenda jump your
fence you got to know you know here's
what I'm going to ask you here is would
you think about that are Kelly sex cult
man what was going on I know you you
know you got your whole life on the
pulse of black culture so what do you
what was going on there it cuz you're in
the Midwest here in Cincinnati yeah yeah
I mean it's just you know what was going
on over the years not so the the pitch
tape came out but that was yeah yeah you
know but our Kelly had the deep pockets
like he a lot of were you getting paid
off no no I didn't get tickets Wisconsin
nothing no I bought 12 play like
everybody else
no he uh you know he had a lot of the
Chicago PD in his pocket yeah and then
when the the money wasn't there can't
help you all sudden now everybody's got
lawsuits and tapes coming out but I
watched this surviving our Kelly and I
was more like
those parents the the two girls now that
he has yeah
those parents brought those girls around
that's like famous a drug man they
brought their dogs around going nah well
he he was uh you know he was exonerated
you know he wasn't guilty I'm like
really there's a tape but there's such
night right and there's such night this
seems to me strange naivety amongst
parents almost because the same thing
happened with the with the Michael
Jackson you know with it with him with
the families just repeatedly bringing
the kids around know when the kids were
like in very precarious situations like
as I even hear it alone either
right but as a parent do you see how
that kind of I mean how how could
something like that kind of happen like
where some parents fame is intoxicating
and you're almost in all I mean thinking
about a religious figure I mean Michael
Jackson was as close as you can get yes
it like Danny or the Pope yeah you know
what I mean like holy [ __ ]
the the biggest star on earth like smite
likes my family once hang out the weird
thing about the surviving Neverland
which I don't believe it I didn't
believe think they were indulging some a
bit but the fact that Mike would just go
to somebody's house in like the valley
yeah just be walking on the street you
better do in addition the street is
checking the mail what the [ __ ] that's
all boy yeah that's so boy right there
huge so that's you you you would be
bougie
yeah that's you thriller coated yeah I
was on stage actually at doing an open
mic Aaron in LA at Westwood Brewing
Company this is probably maybe 13 years
ago and in there's a window outside he
goes to the alley and across Methos and
oz aah HS costume shop and Michael
Jackson pulled up there one night with
his kids and got out of a car after
hours and let him into the costume shop
and he's really in there buying stuff
and then got back into their calling
left yeah I was on stage man is crazy
and I literally looked out the window
and I was like oh Michael Jackson's out
there with the same children go crazy I
thought I would get to meet him I had a
I had a development deal with Quincy
Jones
and we had it for two years and we just
couldn't get couldn't get the show off
the ground for whatever reason but I was
always over like Quincy's house trying
to develop and everything and I kept
just thinking I know I'm gonna go there
one day and Mike's just gonna be there
Wow I know it and quick he's got that
bass story
fuzzy and you know he's not lying some
people like indulge like like that
Michael Jackson story I don't know if I
really believe you yeah I mean like you
I barely believe me but I'm like this
hmm I think it might have been Jackie
yeah I was Tito was not my dude sounds
good I was kidding but like Quincy
stories you know we still the truth like
let's talk about Frank Sinatra the Rat
Pack chili like this I just couldn't get
enough of it because he we had the time
I was at Quincy you'd be like we'd be
trying to put a show together but the
show would take 15 minutes and then it'd
be a two-hour session of him just
talking about life and [ __ ] that he seen
and everything else you know what I mean
I was like they've been through a lot
huh
have you seen at all he's seen it all MJ
all of it what about it was that I heard
a couple years ago that you and Katt
Williams went or had an investment or
something together and it was a
restaurant no I want to say what a
burger or something but I'm not sure I
ever asked me to invest the restaurant
was Nick Lachey really
he opened the bar Lachey's and he he
tried to get any open the bar in the
restaurant but he was trying to get all
like Cincinnati investors hmm so we got
like a couple couple the Reds and the
Bengals and other people in there and
it's just when I talked to my accountant
he was just like restaurants aren't a
good investment not doing that yeah yeah
you don't want to put up any that amount
of money for that
but you're doing so you and Katt
Williams never did like a water burger
and it's like then what I don't where
you hear that have you ever worked with
Katt Williams or met him yeah we yeah
every black comic I know trust work I've
worked with every one of them Wow
what does Katt Williams like because I
saw him one time right he was riding on
a bicycle with that at those uh it had
like these kind of lights in the wheels
down Sunset Boulevard with a couple of
other guys oh really
yeah cats he reminds me of a kid kind of
he marches too
beat his own drum without question like
you know he got realized I've known
Casas 98 Wow
so that's when he first had one tooth in
the front you know and then but he was
it was crazy cat always rolled like he
was a huge star even when he was like
featuring he had a bodyguard Wow
even when he got on JetBlue he had a
bunch of fake chains on like he was
rolling like I'm the guy just waiting
for it yeah and then when he got Friday
the the second Friday it was like that
part was written for him but nobody else
can play that yeah you know I mean other
people could but it was him it was all
him you know what I mean so he always
rolled I can he didn't with it and I
I've said this on stage he did one of
the coolest things a comic ever did for
me after a show and I we were in Austin
Texas and it literally was a - it might
be one other person was me and cat on
the show and it was a weird time in his
career because six months prior we had
at Kent State and he was bubbling like
people knew him but kind of knew him
right and then all sudden I got this
contract and we were at the basketball
arena were the University of Texas plays
I go why would we be there I'm thinking
me and cat are good for like 1500 seats
right not 10,000 right and I get there
and I go oh [ __ ] this guy popped in six
months right Wow so is that pretty crazy
to see what was it like to kind of
witness something like that just like it
happened I don't really think about my
even think it could have happened it was
it the first time you kind of saw
something like that happen yeah I was
like you're more like how like what what
was it that made him pop because I think
we're every now that happens like what
tiffany has and girls trip there's that
one role that people just boom yeah but
I think it's more now you just pepper
people you keep peppering them and then
hope then the amazed like yeah yeah
right but I don't know I you know he
Friday had been out for a couple years
and then the HBO special came out and
whatever he just popped and it was crazy
so we we get them with the show and then
my limo we had two separate limousines
so my buddies were in town and I was
like I asked my driver said yo can I get
the limo for a couple more hours he's
like 300 bucks and I was like all right
so I tried to give him cash and he
wouldn't take it because I needed credit
hard and I go put it it's cash you ain't
got to tell about you just take it
he's did I can't company policy as I'm
having the discussion mmm cap pulled up
and he goes hey Gary what's going on you
going out what are you doing I see I'm
going over a couple hours I said my
driver said he don't take cash needs a
credit card and cackles hold on he took
my driver but around the back of his
limo and to this day I don't know how
much money he gave my driver all the
knows can't walk by me and this is
always said he goes he's yours for the
evening Gary enjoy your night oh yes
they do accept cash they just laughed
and I win Thanks I had never had service
like this in my life that dude I think
he pulled in the club the club we were
in it that's all I mean and then the guy
was there the next my wit I got back to
the room with the bed woke up he was
still standing I know how much [ __ ]
lady can't give this guy but it was just
cool like that
but I heard cat was notorious for like
the hundred our handshakes yeah like
he'd tip somebody just be a hunter in
their hand yeah he didn't I loved that
lifestyle loves to be able to help out
he loves to be able to it's just like
he's a pimp your honor mean he really is
yeah you don't know you don't know what
cat you're getting something yeah I've
personally I'd never seen the wild bad
cat oh it could be a yeah it could be an
alley cat could be nyla can be a house
cat could be a saber-toothed tiger yeah
you know we know in that day I never
I've never had any any real issues any
comics like not as far as confront me or
what about Trap House stuff cuz I know
you know they have a lot of black Trap
House activity have you ever been
involved in anything no damn I'm Fresh
Prince black man the wire man I'm
leaving here a lot of comics hustle
Murch I also coke those are my shoes do
tell me everything you know man
I don't know about levar ball okay do
you think we'll have our ball cares
about his children I don't want to know
yeah big they're mixed like you said
well watered down yeah if that dude was
all black God Lonzo be up you imagine
well personal butanol gonzo never trade
them
no way LeBron who the other one is a
legit amela Yallah mellow dude that's a
soda okay I know right mello Yello
don't you miss good like when I was
growing up they had wild black names
blizzard
dude we had never met a blizzard in my
life you bet a blizzard in the south man
I me had a blizzard magma magma jack yup
magma Quinn siddhis okay go to Facebook
and find me [ __ ] max find me blizzard
I was taking Theo's word for pull up go
to Facebook and just pull up blizzard
really if any names pop up like if you
put up Mary Jones there's gonna be a
mayor Mary Jones has come through if see
how many people are named blizzard it's
Blizz Wilson or Zard Wilson he's not
real come on blizzard Oh Nelly it's not
coming up Nick well let's get to some
other news then we have to pay Joe look
we all know Theo's from Boston right Leo
into private school I'm looking for
first name blizzard yeah
well that could be him down at his
Terence Blizzard lizard Jackson there we
go there he is he's on MySpace face
looks like yeah bro search look he was
gonna come up deals lion they might go
you might go Bobby J just puttin BJ and
see what comes up oh you go gang gang
he's white huh butcher Jax is white as
one no that's just that I mean look he
commits anybody I think it's like Sammy
Sosa he's got all black friend my friend
have 17 friends oh it seems like about
him I'm kind of he was very much kept to
himself did you really know a guy named
Boozer jack a hundred percent from where
is he from
BJ they called him he's from Slidell
Louisiana slide I was outside out of New
Orleans right yep they called him Blizz
some people call him bliss and don't
call him Zard
magma Jackson and I'm not gonna say they
were related but I was just said that a
similar last name
what about coincidence Carter and you
might have had people feel stronger mell
like I'm not ringing a bell I think as a
couple cues in hey let's get to some
more news what else do we have
haha we actually also have a couple
patreon questions for Gary okay let's
get to that then question you got it you
got it all right cool question one from
John page Gary do you feel like you have
a sort of special permission to dive
deeper into jokes that analyze black
culture because your wife is
african-american yeah yeah yeah trust me
yeah you know I'm friends my friends
with me then you got to start playing
the middleman do it if there's any
miscommunication do you know I'm here
just white America don't know yet okay
that's why when you said questions you
got to okay we got two question for Gary
what week she had a lot but we only
picked I picked two of these soon the
second one was from Dalton Wyndham it
was what was the craziest thing you've
ever seen happen at a comedy club
crazy man most of its in the early days
because when you're open mic and you're
hitting bars you see some wild [ __ ] uh
for me personally I uh threw an egg roll
it's no I got a I got AI got escorted I
was in Louisville Kentucky and it was
the night before Thanksgiving was a big
party night and this guy named Spike
Davis had a one look him up spike Davis
legit you gonna find spike Dave lookin
love dude watch watch how fast Mike
Davis pulls up BAM
holy [ __ ] Inez from Louisville what the
[ __ ] okay okay we'll accept oh you know
you can google Spike Davis's right this
Friday we're Carnival Cruise Line
comedian carnival comedian he's doing
cruise lines now yeah yeah that's him
look the University of Louisville hey my
[ __ ] pops up I don't know if I'm saying
bill but this guy okay - this guy spike
Davis he had a Wednesday night in
Louisville and the problem with his show
was there was you know you're you're on
the chairs are on a dance floor and the
later it gets the night turned into a
club
so the comedy supposed start at 8:00 it
should be over by 10:00 people get well
there's the show starts late then I'm
the headliner so I'm going up late so by
the time I hit the stage pushing 10:30
10:45 so people start to come in that
want to go party so you're fighting
these you know people here laughing but
the people are here they're ready to
party like get this [ __ ] dude onto
stage we're at a party so you're dealing
with it so I start getting hecklers so
I'm having fun with this one guy like
we're going back and forth and it's
actually galvanizing the crowd because
now everybody's in on it but did I say
hey man why don't you come on stage man
we could play to dozens you know not
knowing to people didn't like me so I
turn around and I think from me to you
there is two brothers gold fronts didn't
like they have [ __ ] to lose they were
just on the stage and I went oh [ __ ] I
jumped off the stage into the DJ booth
he had the mic back then I get do when
your life's in danger yeah you can just
wire this what I think Parker so I'm
still got the mic talking shoot through
him right and they're getting upset so
they literally they escorted him out I I
didn't know they had undercover people
in the club right police officers they
escort the guys out they literally on
that line they had me duck him down took
me out a back door and got in a car and
the guy had his pistol out driving me to
the hotel and I was like I was like what
the [ __ ] going I go do he's playing
safe I think they were just different
they didn't tell me clear those guys hit
were trouble yeah so they was I we're
just playing it safe you know take my
hotel so I get back to the hotel and
they go they were gonna have somebody
[ __ ] in the parking lot what till I left
the next day I go dude I'm leaving
tonight so this dude fought and I was
living in Cincy so it's just like a
minor two hour drive this is the
Underground Railroad no so the dude my
locally litter he followed me back to I
got on 75 and I got once I got on the
highway he like flex flashes lights and
he veered off and then I just drove back
home I was like what the [ __ ] was all
that
why does spike call me like after the
weekend and goes amen they loved you
down here man they wants you back
be backing that [ __ ] did he waited like
four days like I'm gonna forget I got
escorted out a man they love you know
hate never brought up
I got escorted out Goodes rushed the
stage they love you down here man they
wants you back I will never be back in
your club bro never
I got sucker-punched in Detroit after a
show oh wow I've been 20 years this is
minor [ __ ] yeah thank you actually and
all this [ __ ] happened early none of
this [ __ ] has happened in the last 10
years right so I'm in Detroit and after
my show I go this place called the
Lyceum right I'm not lying
like oh [ __ ] I'm like this oh my sis
legit you find Lyceum nightclub in
Detroit Michigan
yeah I don't know I sell it I don't know
how you spell Lyceum was the name
Detroit Lyceum Hansen to a kid I went to
junior high way I'm just sayin man he's
out there oh they never heard of it it
says uh-uh watch all that [ __ ] pops up I
mean Cuban eyes ten years ago yeah yeah
yeah it never happened there's pictures
of it man that here doesn't that could
be anything you smelling it wrong
there's a s s in it [ __ ] got on a
spell is your problem
that guy is doing fine dude this is
called Lyceum elie-san I think it was a
my front gives it the beer the front I
eat in the front
nah [ __ ] this he likes easy lounge oh my
god Gary tell the truth again so anyways
closed all right so I'm at Elysium Wild
Thing got three stars dude hey shut up I
look it was after my show we'd go to
Liam right and when I walked in like
these three girls is like here could get
a picture I was it yeah so take a
picture with him then go to the bar got
my buddy Reggie and his wife right so
the bartender comes and goes $125 for
three drinks I was like what I go how
much the drinks they go well those girls
said you were buying their drinks too
without even looking at the girls I
looked at the bars I go oh I'm not bond
of [ __ ] drinks it here tonight and
all so I turned around the girls like
you call us [ __ ] and I was like nah I
said [ __ ] per se
but I never got to say that I don't know
where these fists came from but these
dudes went Bing Bing Bing like I got hit
three times from men yeah over the girls
right I don't even know who the dudes
were to this day Yeah right
and uh I literally hit my buddy ready to
go let's go man place is wack so so I we
just walked out of club now I'm in the
car and I'm in the rear view mirror like
looking like this to make sure I'm not
cut up I'm fine and then his wife comes
out
Reggie's wife comes out her girlfriend
she's like she's hysterical she got
scared you all right I see yeah yeah I
go what happened she was that was like
the funniest and scariest [ __ ]
they said cuz you were getting hit but
still talking oh yeah it happened so
fast so really I was like I ain't called
by a [ __ ] let's go rich place whack
and all I was thinking was I was on I
just got hired to be on house of pain
that that Tyler Perry's do you want to
get in trouble I answer filming yet I
don't want to show up dotted up yeah
there was nothing in my in me this had
fight back or figure out what's going I
just said get the [ __ ] out
yeah you know this could get worse and I
just I'm just so glad to have any marks
on me do you have a knot up here they
got me pretty good really but I ducked
it's got me I got punched by on steroids
earning and hit with a fence board once
that more to grow by a guy now I says I
got no I got hit nervous man if you're
like in an all-black environment you get
nervous sometimes not at all yeah I
don't really get nervous anymore you
just I would I wish I could get that
feeling and when I first start doing Oh
nervous on stage just that the drive to
the comedy club or wherever you're about
to perform I wish I could get that
feeling again yeah cuz I felt like you
just felt like your senses was on twenty
you didn't want to hear nothing you
couldn't talk to anybody the car you're
just you're so huh yeah I wish I get
that feeling like the Open Mic days God
it was such a good feeling inside and
it's so funny that you so scared them
and you can't go back to that fee can't
just can't go back in is no way to get
back there really oh it's it's like it
almost felt like when you were playing
high school football like before they go
yeah ever like that it's a closest
feeling I've had to that you know what I
mean so it's like nowadays you just it's
you know you're not like nervous you're
just like okay it's a job back then you
it's not about ticket prices not about
take
sailes not about what the check is it's
just rate of I want these people to
laugh at these jokes I hope these jokes
work yeah now there's so much else that
goes with it you're looking at your guy
did you count the row yeah
all right what kind of percentage deal
we got yeah this is your amazing
teriyaki chicken right we got where's my
I think [ __ ] teriyaki chicken you back
then you like this plastic Cambodian
yeah you guys don't have a sense eeeh
yeah
the [ __ ] round ring of Fiji fake
Cambodians dude Cambodians bro hey let's
take this question that came right here
for you Gary Owen stop Gary what's up
the old gang gang what's it like being a
Bengals fan I can name two bangles
players of her Chad Ochocinco and the
endangered species quarterback so I just
want to know what it what's that like
man Tyler Eifert aqui would you ever met
a key mm-hmm think he's a good dude he
lives in Cincy does he
mm-hmm hey you know tragedy is like his
son pays some was a really good ice floe
uh player and passed away had like some
weird has him attack or something came
out of nowhere like it shouldn't have
killed him yeah he passed away he's a
good dude uh listen man I don't know how
to [ __ ] her down though to Bingle's
counter I for the greatest offensive
tackle on the NFL Xanthia Munoz yeah
like and that is not even up for debate
yeah suck a [ __ ] dude well I mean yeah
not funny no but he's not a position
player he's not like you know yeah it's
tough me to bingos faint man so I can
abuse relationships like Ike and Tina
Turner just keep coming back for more
abuse yeah but we got a new coach kind
of regime
you know I T yeah I caught a lot a
little flak last year because I did a
video I was kidding and I did a video
like hey Bengals uh front office you
guys can maybe take care of this year I
want to go to a game or I'm I'm like one
of the it's like literally me and
Nikolas share the only two people out
there that are vocal about being Bengals
fans yeah that are on TV and and Penner
out there in entertainment and I called
four tickets one time and they said no
and I went really like my publicist
called she goes this is never happened
here
like they just said no and then the guy
said like an eight page email explaining
why they could not leave me tickets to
the game and there was 8,000 empty seats
at the stadium and I went you got to be
kidding me and then the players start
diem and me like will leave you tickets
like the players write hilarious and
then uh it's not about buying the
tickets it's just like that's your squad
yeah you rep them you go on the NFL
Network ESPN they know you think because
your angles guy yeah they know
everything is shouldn't know everything
that's going on well I mean that's what
you do like like if you see like Seattle
they got a 12th man Seattle has a suite
the Seahawks were when their celebs come
in that are Seahawks fans they put them
in this suite and go to Atlanta you got
Samuel Jackson pumping up the Falcons
for the game on the on the on the the
big screen and everything it's like
that's just what you do you take care of
Robert Kraft always takes care of the
Boston guys right yeah he's got to well
they should include something fun and
something exciting do you do you feel
like what they say in the email what was
his it was some about revenue sharing
how they can't leave a guy go oh my god
when they went to England three years
ago the Redskins left me tickets I was
like yeah be kidding me the Redskins
front office was like yeah we got you
left me feel passes tickets and I like
the Bengals like nah can't go and then
last year so the do you still go to the
games yeah cuz it's not that I'm a fan
of the Bengals in there they they
wrapped my city and the players have
nothing to do with that it's just as
some mom and pops run organization and
you know that it was crazy because last
year I did the funny video go hey
Bingle's you think about go to again as
you guys maybe we can take care of me I
gave like a wink like an Instagram post
so I guess they got a lot of emails from
fans go how you not take care of our guy
you know and then uh so they did this
that's what they did they say yeah we're
gonna leave you tickets and field passes
and everything to the first home game
but we're gonna do a contest where
people are gonna send in like their
email and then we're gonna pick a name
to get to go the game with you that's it
great so they kind of used it to get
people on their email list they get
start sending them like
like packages like hey we got a two-game
package for you to go to so then I go
the game with these two fans had a good
time with them and they took care of me
so then I the Pittsburgh I found I'm
gonna be in town like a weeks notice and
it's the Steeler game so I sent an email
to the girl that was my contact ago hey
I'm gonna be in town this week you think
it's cool if I come to the game she goes
all know this game is way too popular oh
wow so they put you in your flesh I
posted damn really Bingle's guess who
called bingos from being a pittsburgh
for office Wow guess let him ticket to
the game it's very the [ __ ] Steelers
damn and Steelers like like was like we
take care of people who's like this it's
a goddamn shame Wow and do you think
it's because of the color of your skin
no not at all
it's just how the Bengals do business
that's their the it's not a very good
front-office
and then so I had will Packer coming in
town he's a Bucs fan and I was very
anima with the Bengals like if I could
pick one game you could say Kara me and
and I want to show this guy this is one
of the top movie producers in the world
I was like he's a bucks man so me and
will always he comes to Cincinnati when
the Bucs play and I go to Tampa when the
minnows buy the Bucks in Tampa and it's
only over four years because they're in
different conferences and well was
coming and I asked the bengals you know
and they see how we got you they left me
row 34 will Packer oh it no way it's
pretty good man it's terrible really for
the one of biggest producers in in the
world movie producers I don't know he is
I don't know a lot of people you don't
know will Packer uh-uh okay he did think
like a man ride along girls trip night
school stomp the yard
oh wow just show it show debuted
yesterday and on Oprah's network
ambitions wills like the guy right now
Wow he's got the big deal with Universal
I kiss his movies he doesn't have one L
yet all his movies have made money yeah
I just don't know any players oh yeah I
recognize him
Wow yeah maybe they're just a little bit
behind the time you think you think
let's get a couple more there there's
his movies crap Wow just some hitters
man
ringer that sounds bad what men want
Jacobs Emmys Jacob's Ladder striking
please up peeping toms Straight Outta
Compton right along I'm in let's see it
lets uh what are the news we got Nick
see Bella Thorne her phone was hacked
and they found some of her nudes and she
was being threatened and so she decided
to release them on her own and to get
out in front of it and then Whoopi
Goldberg was critical of just her taking
pictures in the beginning oh yeah and
put them in listen if you're famous I
don't care how old you are you don't
take nude pictures of yourself you were
one person but she said listen when
they're hacking you they're hacking all
of your stuff so whether it's one
picture or a million pictures once you
take that picture yeah it goes into the
cloud and it's available to any hacker
who wants it and if you don't know that
in 2019 but this is an issue you you I
agree with her I think mm-hmm and then I
agree with her a lot of people took
issue with that and said like her logic
was flawed like are you never gonna buy
stuff online because your credit card
could get hacked and Bella Thorne put
out a tearful response to Whoopi for her
victim-blaming
essentially yeah well it's a it wasn't
it wasn't mean that it was just I think
it was Whoopi's tone it came across very
aggressive and if she could have said
the same thing it was like look I get it
you wish you could take pictures and
send to your husband or your wife my
wife sent me what time I said don't ever
[ __ ] do that again don't do that [ __ ]
and she is what I go don't I say dude
you just can't risk it yeah don't ever
send me no new pic ever Joe went off on
I said don't do that [ __ ] lastly I
wanted your [ __ ] out there and I got a
deal with that you know I mean he's
[ __ ] jacking off to my wife and I
said hit a Polaroid blizzard Jackson
would have definitely jaycara now
question let Genevieve conquistador was
the other guys
now coincidence
Carter apparently you guys grew up
around some [ __ ] weak [ __ ]
powderpuff [ __ ] dude yeah that
we can find people are using electronics
like day and not even thinking about
what they do or what they're capable of
I mean that's one thing it's like it's
kind of wild that there isn't a class
that shows you all the things that
actually go on when you have a phone and
when you're sending photos to people and
all of this like the transmission the
things that possibly could get stolen
how things give you taken that almost
seems like it should be a course that
should be for children these days
because you don't realize the level of
the intense power of a phone that you
have in your hand when you send someone
a photo you don't need yeah you're not
even thinking oh it could go out
somewhere but this thing's totally
capable of that you know you're not even
knowing what laws are even attached to
it that they could be taken what you're
saying and using it to advertise against
you it seems kind of bizarre it also
seems like to me also like bella thorne
seems like a little bit of a [ __ ]
nutcase
but so does Whoopi so I'm not surprised
at both like I said that was that was
all her tone like she was basically
scolding bella thorne instead of a Sam
look it's not your fault at all but he
just got to be careful you got to
realize once you send those nudes you
take that risk
yeah this is not drawing a picture and
handing it to someone yeah you know yeah
for real I think that was just all her
tone yeah you know I think it's a good
point and any most dramatic actresses
little sensitive
yeah sensitive creatures man insane they
also say Oh at a certain point I worked
with that girl on the bad baby music
video and she was um who Bella Thorne
yeah and she was I mean she's definitely
attractive but I don't know I could see
anybody any of those people haven't like
an ego that was just to me was
astronomical you know but then also
she's a big star I guess what's what's
her biggest credit she was on it she
came up on a Disney show and was doing
that for a while and then now she does
she she doesn't do like huge studio
movies but she does like the teen stuff
like that so she wasn't in the trap she
was shot now
I love the trap six I don't know her
what about this what
do we have Nicolas that's kind of bad
for news yeah weird about 95 minutes
okay cool
wow we're deep man that's what I do man
time with me just flies by tell me you
have any good Gary minke stories out of
Cincinnati or no holy [ __ ] how do you
know Carrie Mickey well who doesn't know
Gary Mickey for our listeners Gary mall
holy [ __ ] you talk about taking me back
hockey you're gonna get burned
eventually Oh Gary manky is a monkey is
a magical little israelite that like
lost half of his house and like I don't
know what happened to him Gary mate but
he's like a guy who books a real person
that's not Blizzard Jackson oh sure it
is
make he's real I don't believe anything
you say anymore Gary make okay Gary
Mickey was a guy that but let me tell
you the good and bad thing about Gary
Mickey if you were struggling and you
had a halfway decent name and said gear
I need $500 yeah he would find you a gig
somewhere yep somewhere about yo Dover
Delaware somewhere I got you got you
know me but just trust you're gonna get
burned at some point yeah and Gary
burned me New Year's Eve in Orlando I'll
never forget it
I had it probably two thousand five or
six I bet so he goes Gary man look I'm
on one New Year's Eve this year I said
all right I'm I'm okay but I'm not
really moving tickets enough I have to
be at a comedy club to move tickets you
can't put me at a place where they don't
normally see comedy okay you know I mean
so he books me at some club that has a
stage that doesn't do comedy but they do
shows right I'm thinking 12 people were
there and they kept holding the show and
I go guys they're not coming like I'm
telling to do that's their go like a bus
is not about to pull up and 500 people
get out it let's just do this 12 people
and get on with it right they have a
money right
they the club guy like well I make no
money man I'm like well my deals with
Mickey so I'm calling Gary like yeah man
we got you we got you I got it I could
Gary I need something man I've done so
basically lunch there's trying it [ __ ]
so I flew down only thing Gary got me
was the hotel
yeah you know what I mean and then it
was funny because the guy his business
partner Gary Mickey is a stumpy white
dude yeah so he had this he had this
other black dude that was his the
co-promoter on this foot Mickey right so
the black just went to pick me from the
airport and when I left then I go don't
worry about it
I'll need to ride home I don't need to
see I'll deal with Gary I don't know you
like that right so the black guy had the
nerve like a year later to show up and
call the Tampa Improv to say he knows me
and wanted tickets to the show and I go
no that guy's got a bottle a steak so
they buy his tickets so then afterwards
he's coming up when you're the
Cincinnati Bengals all of a sudden then
he comes out by afterwards like he like
don't even bring up the fact you guys
still owe me money from the years Wow
and he's got like his whole crew with
them and they're taking pictures with me
and he goes yeah I'm gonna get one of
them t-shirts man when the mergers like
Mike Bradley charged him right he was
like so just stared at Brad Brad was
like you know 20 hours it was like a
stare-off really he looked at me he
liked the brand I go and I'm like I'm
like just went off for t-shirt like he
just didn't to be embarrassed he thought
he was just gonna grab some [ __ ] for his
people like we're boys like did you
forget what happened in pay me
that's minke bruh you know man I haven't
worked maybe since but you know oh
you're late yeah especially in that part
of the country yeah Tampa to Richmond Oh
Lord oh up to the Midwest Missouri the
stray animal belt yeah that guy Mac you
know good I'll tell you this Gary got
the best story ever man he had you know
Gary used to carry a bunch of tickets
with him in his pockets and he'd give
them out to people for stuff around town
for free stuff you know anybody a you go
to restaurant never pay for food with
Gary well I would end up paying for food
he would say well he's gonna treat me
the guy wouldn't the manager would not
accept the tickets and you know how to
pay for the dinner right oh so one night
Gary gets a couple milkshakes from
McDonald's right and he gets one for now
and one for later dude you know
and uh and so he's walking across his
parking lot it's in Cincinnati and they
had got a couple of black girls fighting
right so he goes over there to watch and
polish off one of the shakes right so
the problem is he gets a little too
close with his phone he starts filming
them you know so he's holding one hand
one milkshake in his hand the other one
pressed against his chest watching these
ladies fight he gets too close they turn
on him and start coming after him right
now he starts running his pockets are
full of all those tickets that he's
really when he pulls his shorts down now
he can't run and he's got two shakes
dude and these girls beat [ __ ] are
you sure you got beat up
oh they beat a shake and four fists
right out of my last breath and the
whole time he was trying to he was
getting beaten but also trying to hold
one of the shakes like double bear
remember double dare ya yeah that's
great it's slimed yeah he got [ __ ]
smacked up double dare is real
Oh is there Jackson I stumble there was
a real show look up look up BJ and I see
if that's a person man but cuz that's
who we're missing he played for the
Bulls thank you okay yeah when Gary when
the funnybone open in Cincinnati which
was in Newport Kentucky back in like
2004 he hired a relative of mine that he
didn't know was a relative of mine and I
go because yeah me I got this young girl
man she's like hustling tickets and
she's out on the streets he's moosh it
and I told Gary go uh that's my cousin I
go she's on drugs dude she's gonna rip
you off eventually and he got he goes I
don't know but him crackheads caboose
from tickets hahahahaha it was my cousin
ever lived on the street he'll get
anybody like Gary then when she showed
up she's like okay I don't know how
she's getting them tickets out there
he's a hustler man you're gonna I was
like in the clientele show with a lot of
her friends like Tuesday nights hit the
funny bone whoo oh they weren't moving a
lot of food sounds like a lot like a
12-step meeting Gary Owen thanks so much
for coming and joining us man really
appreciate it for us yeah you're welcome
what a guy never closes I know thank you
man yeah you're welcome
try being on time
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]